não posso falar do júri
sei que todos os canais sala e não só
possui neste momento não vamos mulher
maravilha
vamos dizer porque descobriu o dom do
ico2 fazer ler as outras pessoas nem se
no dia que nem se contou minha mãe foi
uma dificuldade enorme porque nem se com
quilinhos a mais
é tarefa minha tia o corpo parceria com
a autora é em casa estava minha tia
tentar fazer com que eu saí do vento da
mãe
o esforço era tarde mas eu era talmo dê
decidiu a minha tia pegar uma garrafinha
de óleo de palma lubrificar a minha mãe
de uma ponta ótimo para que eu saí do
ventre da minha mãe quando pegou a minha
tia por gomo entregou à minha mãe ea
minha mãe
pra mim começou a senhora nesse meu
filho está tão bonito
está todo mundo focado e eu disse à
minha mãe droga que o ferido é então a
partir daquele dia
não parei de fazer e ações deste governo
eu sou mais novo da família a minha mãe
diz que eu nem se contanto que eu
gostava de comer muito e tinha o um ano
de cinema
ela estava na cozinha fazer o calo praça
tradicional de sangue como principal do
peixe
outra vez com óleo do paula outra vez
com aldo paulo
ei se distraiu e deixou alê perto do
taxa da lei
verinha ninguém na panela no ano quem
estava com ele tá tudo
um bebê de um ano a minha mãe quando
chegou era só de itália chamou os meus
irmãos estavam todo queimado mas por ter
um dom do rio
a minha mãe disse que aquela de uma dura
da lei maria nesta altura
looooool na manteiga e no google
lubrificado todo e eu fui
e gosto de momentos em que a vida não
nos olhamos o lado olhar no fuso rolar
nos encontramos ninguém para nos fazer e
nós concentramos e nós vamos ali é vai
passar
então é isso que o fmi nos meus oito
anos eo meu pai quando fundado na altura
decidiu viajar ligado para portugal
foram portugal irá julgá lo com as
linhas e mais linhas normais depois dos
gols para viajar é um menino brincar e
fazer a comparação
rui torneio escravo das 6 mas sempre é
que cada vez que o quadro é louvável
porque dava um jeito de ter um trunfo a
bombar no sufoco uma super in
quem é que não comeu açúcar e quem aqui
não não márai feita como açúcar e parque
chico era minha alegria na altura ser
menino de recado das minhas margens mas
foi complicado porque os jogadores
começaram a dizer que não poderia fazer
brotar não ia aguentar
então ouvi que só para bater nas pessoas
quando elas já se tornou metade deles
então mas quando é que seu nome não pode
já sem o plano baixo do braço em sentar
até metade dizem que existe na minha
cabeça foi uma teoria já que quem é que
não conhece já cria uma jaca verdade
feira peguei vez que já está passando
mas no braço dos dois
tirei um pouquinho o cabelo tem baixo no
brasil e disse que a partir de hoje os
homens as minhas mas não batem matos
cheguei em casa e às minhas irmãs a mais
velha o nome disse o piloto
tu tens que aprovasse combate olho para
fazermos o jantar ali senão não vou mais
sair acho que jamais após bater mas
agora eu sou uma entrada a 24 de
fevereiro em casa a ver o moço primeiro
porque depois ela mandou arrancar aqui
tudo outra vez mas lee a maior alegria
da minha vida os meus pais decidiram
manter a decisão da empresa
eu achava que era a maior alegria da
minha vida
o país duas ter que descobrir novos
horizontes novas coisas mas sempre com
um iene
vamos meter medo do bicho por viajar com
os pais a minha vez
agora você já não basta e ela já é
chegou o momento de ir embora porque eu
me min shin tinha e uma mochila nas
costas cheio banana mandou saudade
mas vocês têm nenhum empregado do mesmo
nível de cargas estável mas caiu do do
país na união com mala pesada no final
do mês como se lê nos costume une a
carregar o que ia fazer a graça dos meus
pais a alegar a alegria dos morros mas
por que eu
ao chegar em portugal os meus para o
olharam para mim desculpas se do avião
frio no inverno as minhas mas nesse caso
para viajar nunca saque
o casal com ela toda a bagagem que o
carregado
estávamos jogando começou
o vídeo é coletar meu marido frio à
noite
o gol levou o agora famoso as duas fases
morro arrastou o país poderá todos eles
muito me taxi to ruin liga o porto a
gente bonita mas não mais bonitos que
sabem que são tomé 2009 10
eu tenho esse problema será velado falou
às vezes a língua nem sequer ido em um
táxi pra casa e eu vou dizer fogo ver
num prédio daqueles maggi não é como o
pai mora num prédio globo
o pai tanto tempo com o pai tá cá nós
passávamos prédio era prédio passava os
prédios caminhos puros press prédios e
prédios de perder por 2 1 numa zona
aberta baratas imaginar atas
um cara parceiro de seu pai estamos a
passar por outra não só pelo nosso
bairro
vamos a entrar grega pode ser que mais
humana
entramos em dubai
logo na entrada ela sujeira de uma ponta
a outra era pessoas
a apae é água num chafariz é a água por
exemplo uma ponta a outra era filos da
passagem em cima de casas populares x1
colados a outro não sabia pacote e ao
fim ele sair mas é aqui que a gente mora
no bairro de mangabeira em sabe como ele
fez
já joão vai se é que sai todos os dias
vamos mandar dinheiro quando nós aí
cheguei em casa a primeira coisa
cheguei em casa minha mãe não pôs à
frente era uma perna e norma no fraga o
amante uma perna do frango e norma muito
arroz sentia como eu tinha um nome da
minha mãe e chorei porque estava tão
satisfeito
o sorriso era tarde eo país andava o
filho andré cavalo qual sabe que esse
valor o filho a metal coco a deus o
braço para o ip6 braz a síndica com o
braço do meu pai estava completa minha
felicidade é o dia e aí comecei a e é é
a natura cheguei já estava uma trovoada
que enfrentar
alunos professores português não
influencia no brasil a minha língua
estranha para todos
naquela altura falava eu não eu senão eu
não sei que vai ter sempre o mesmo o tj
preto
a pessoa vai explicar os outros alunos e
não olhava pra meses ela não respeitar o
marcelo é coisa do passado e quer saber
a linha liga era uma língua tão
complicado mas eu tenho problema de cada
vez que olhava pra mim com aquele ar
decididas já leva na ribeira
não falei a minha língua materna e poder
voltar a treinar normalmente levo a
minha língua e nem sequer é muito
dinheiro
outros consideram uma vez que passei
minha juventude
estudei como já disse é sempre com
vontade de fazer e fiz nesses vales vou
regressar a camp país que eu saí novo
vou dar oportunidade aos nacionais como
conhecerem de conhecer o trabalho de
conhecer a vontade do roteiro
fazer risos a vontade que eu tenho de
fazer os outros inteira e sol com um
sorriso bonito
podemos ultrapassar as dificuldades só
com sorriso bonito poderão estar em
santo andré com todas as dificuldades
que o país atravessa e sentir que não
atenderem somos tanto mesmo e vamos dar
a volta por cima e vamos fazer com que
saibam como é que estamos sendo
construído unido caiu sobre santo - que
não só está nestas aulas até hoje fazer
lhe todas aquelas que estão à minha
volta e não só tem um problema em fazer
as minhas filhas não entendem qualidade
daquilo que eu falo mas cada vez que eu
chego em casa começa aí e eu cheguei em
casa hoje saí do trabalho cheguei em
casa por volta das seis da manhã estava
minha filha já estudando
ela olhou pra mim com o aro e não tava
meio meio preocupado e assustado
ela não tem pai que continha já tem
cinco anos diz o pai orgulhoso que eu
tenho compromisso hoje 4 dex criança
estava louco que sai bem certeza ele vai
à vontade você é e nem vou fazer o que
sei fazer que é fazer rir das pessoas
pensa todo o planeta peço a todos que
são amantes de um bom sorriso de uma boa
galera que continue a partilhar o do gre
o dom de fazer rir os outros porque só
assim podemos realmente fazer o planeta
tornar um planeta melhor
nisso o planeta líderes que têm de me
traria um planeta de dentes sair mas aí
vem um planeta vou ter sido xingado mas
hariri um planeta de quem não sabe mas
aí um paleta de nos todos os aparelhos é
é a mulher isso ajuda